[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are in beautiful Davenport Iowa with a
massive crowd welcome all of you thank
you for being here
wow and in a little more than one month
the very first Republican caucus will be
held right here in this state as it
should be and by the way in just moment
the candidate leading the Republican
field by far Donald J Trump will join us
for the full hour
tonight let's be clear in
2024 the stakes could not be any higher
after three years under Joe Biden our
country is imploding on every level our
economy is wrecked by inflation our
Southern border is an utter disaster the
American people are not safe take a look
what I would say that is unique about
the environment that we're in right now
in my career is that while there may
have been times over the years where
individual threats could have been
higher here or there than where they
might be right now I've never seen a
time where all the threats or so many of
the threats are all elevated all at
exactly the same time that's what makes
this environment that we're in now so
fraught are you concerned that
International terrorism threats to the
Homeland are rising as the Border
continues to be broken I am concerned
that we are in an elevated threat
environment a heightened threat
environment from foreign terrorist
organizations um for a whole host of
reasons um and obviously their ability
to exploit uh any Port of Entry
including our Southwest border is a
source of concern concern now that was
the FBI director Christopher Ray today
on Capitol Hill make no mistake uh our
wideopen Joe Biden border is now a
massive National security nightmare it
is a clear and present danger and it is
only getting worse every day under
President Biden in the past two years
well over what 6,000 illegal immigrants
from Afghanistan have crossed our
Southern border along with 3,000
Egyptians more than 600 Iranians you
know Iran the number one state sponsor
of Terror more than 500 syrians 12,000
Russians and a whopping 26,000 people
from the from China this is a dire
National Security crisis but that is
only one part of the problem for years
America's bloated bureaucracy it has now
become politicized that includes the FBI
the doj which have wasted precious time
and resources with political motivated
witch hunts what they're looking into
traditional Catholics or angry parents
that go to Schoolboard meetings or
pro-life Advocates that are not non
violent you know Trump supporters Donald
Trump himself instead of investigating
real threats like terrorism human
trafficking drug trafficking gang
violence the FBI their hyperarithmetical
put me back in the White House their
reign is over their reign will be over
and they know it and America will be a
free Nation once again we're not a free
Nation right now we don't have Free
Press we don't have free
anything in 2016 I
declared I am your voice today I add I
am your Warrior I am your Justice and
for those who have been wronged and
betrayed I am your retribution I am your
retribution
not going to let this
happen now that's become a controversy
among the left
wrong as he said earlier but we'll play
that for him and get a response tonight
now that's an important promise
America's weaponized politicized
bureaucracy it's got to be dismantled
the far-left hacks and the media Mob Of
course they disagree and once again they
are predicting Doom and Gloom if Donald
Trump is elected here's the Washington
Post yesterday quote the fear of a
looming Trump dictatorship and this is
today's headline from salon.com
Americans are sleepwalking into a trump
dictatorship that's now their favorite
word over at fake news all cable news
channels you know they're featuring you
know the same brand of fear-mongering
obviously it's clear they don't want to
talk about Joe Biden and his failed
record take a look dictatorship is that
what we would have if we reelect Donald
Trump I think it's it's a very very real
threat and concern I think the phrase
sleepwalking into a dictatorship um
should wake people up correct me if I'm
wrong it's not going to be the kind of
dictatorship with concentration camps
and martial law overnight is it that's
not what we're going to get we're going
to get Trump borrowing from the oran
playbook in Hungary from the Modi
playbook in India and what does that
look like Jason what would that look
like here in American fears of a
dictatorship the alarming prediction for
a second Trump term Liz Cheney is right
what she said that we are sleepwalking
into a Donald Trump dictatorship if
people don't wake up and remember what
Donald Trump was to to the four years
what he tried to do to our
democracy here's a thing we already know
what would happen under a trump
presidency why because he's already been
president lower taxes stronger growth a
secure border peace in the Middle East
new trade deals energy and
dependence and a push to reform our
bloated bureaucracy uh there was no
dictatorship we did not lose our
constitutional rights we did not go to
war the people who hate Donald Trump
they simply have been and continue to
lie to you now it's Joe Biden who has
been using the justice system his doj to
inflict retribution against his
political Rivals and it's Joe Biden who
called Donald Trump supporters a quote
threat to America America uh the very
guy that says Maga Republican oh making
America great is somehow bad and it's
Joe Biden who is leading this country
into the brink of yet another possible
war and that's why Donald Trump is now
beating Joe Biden in almost every major
poll take a look at your screen latest
messenger Harris survey has Trump
against Joe Biden up by six points so
now the big question can Donald Trump
seal the deal and get the country back
on track hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else